all right new york governor andrew cuomo
on defense as bipartisan backlash mounts
over his handling
of covid 19 nursing home deaths
i want to set the record straight on
nursing homes
we created a void
by not producing enough public
information fast enough then it was
exploited
with misinformation people playing
politics
republicans playing politics
personal attacks personal agendas
well republican lawmakers in the state
are moving to form an impeachment
commission to find out what really
happened here to react is new york
assembly republican confederates
confederates leader will barclay welcome
to the show thank you so much uh for
joining us so you see that
defense by cuomo the latest of many what
do you make of him saying oh there was
just a void of information that was the
real issue here
well i find that an irony really i mean
we've been trying to get this
information from the department of
health
in new york for months and months and we
kept getting stonewalled
and that just did raise suspicions why
are we getting stonewalled was it
because uh
it went against the uh governor's story
about providing great leadership during
this uh
pandemic or was it for some other reason
then we had the bombshell report by the
democratic attorney general
in new york that said the governor was
under reporting nursing home deaths by
as much as 50 percent
and then in a closed-door political
meeting uh the top aide of the governor
said well we froze we didn't provide
this information because we were worried
about a department of justice
investigation
and we were worried about the political
fallout so there seems to be a lot of
evidence out there pointing to the fact
that there was some sort of cover-up
and myself and my colleagues feel
strongly that we ought to get to the
bottom of it we feel like we owe it to
those
families who lost loved ones in nursing
homes assemblyman i want to look at
where we go moving forward where this
commission will
be going forward but let's take a quick
look back one more time
to the best of your knowledge and i
understand we need to still investigate
what happened here but why
why was this order put into place to
send people back to nursing homes
well you know that's a great question it
does require further investigation
the governor's line is we're worried
about the hospitals and others filling
up
and we had to move people out of the
hospital in the nursing homes to me
it just seems logical that when you send
someone that has coveted infection into
a nursing home
even if the covet is already in the
nursing home it's going to increase
infection rates in those nursing homes
and indeed there have been some studies
i think the empire report recently came
out with one saying that
by doing that they caused up to a
thousand uh additional deaths
in nursing homes so but that needs to be
looked at that's one issue and we can
look at that in the legislature we ought
to do that right away we ought to use
subpoena power we ought to get
the commissioner health uh to testify
under oath and find out exactly what
happened and we need to do that because
we want to prevent
something like this happening again so
that's one issue but we also still have
the whole idea of a cover-up and why
weren't they providing that information
that doesn't help
public health officials it doesn't help
the legislature craft policy doesn't
help the public
oh just a void not a mistake uh he's
made that clear
but mr assemblyman if if if republicans
are calling for an impeachment council
that's one thing
if democrats actually join and make it
bipartisan that's a whole other ball
game we've
we've heard based on what was done to
ron kim the assemblyman democrat
intimidation that there might be more
interest amongst democrats what is the
political climate in new york
of democrats and appetite to really do
something about cuomo here on this issue
well i don't think they have been moving
as fast as i would like to see but i do
think there's cracks in the political
wall of trying to
maybe protect a fellow democrat who
happens to be the governor
uh because of reasons like him bullying
assembly
members like ron kim his staff was out
apparently pushing
this narrative with legislators i think
that gets people's backs up
and i do think the public outcry we have
people like janice dean who have been
great been a leader
on trying to bring light to this issue i
think there is political pressure so
if you ask me that question maybe a
month ago i said that chances are
unlikely but the way things are
progressing
uh i'm optimistic and i hope they don't
see this as a partisan thing it really
is a bipartisan thing those families
that were lost these nursing homes
weren't democrats republicans
they were new yorkers and they deserve
accountability and they deserve the
legislature to get to the bottom of this
well assemblyman we appreciate you being
here this morning i think you're right i
think it is bipartisan we're going to
continue to follow this and see where
this
investigation leads hopefully to
accountability important to note that we
did reach out to governor cuomo's office
have not heard back as of yet but we
will keep you updated if we do in fact
hear back state representative william
barclay thanks for being with us this
morning
thank you